the terms mastery learning are used a
lot these days but I want to do a video
on them because they can mean different
things to different people and I want to
talk about what it means at least in a
Khan Academy context so to give us some
perspective let's actually just start
with traditional learning and think
about where it works and maybe where it
doesn't work and then we could think
about why mastery learning might address
some of those issues so let's say we are
in a middle school math class and right
now the classroom is focused on negative
numbers we have we're going to work on
that for a couple of weeks so this is
negative numbers right over here and
after a couple of weeks of lecture and
homework we we give a test and let's say
a certain student that we're following
gets an 80% on that test so he or she
knows a lot of the material but doesn't
know some of the material here maybe
doesn't know some of the material here
maybe doesn't know some of the material
over here so these are gaps these are
gaps in their understanding so these let
me label these correctly these are gaps
and even though we've taken the trouble
of giving an assessment a quiz a test
and we identify these gaps the whole
class including that student will then
move on to the next concept so let's say
the next concept that we now work on
maybe we do it for a few more weeks
according to the lesson plan is now
basic exponents so this is basic
exponents and the same thing happens we
have some lecture and homework for a few
weeks and then at the end of that we
have a test and let's say on that test
the student gets a 70% so he or she
knows a good bit of the material but
there's still some pretty significant
gaps let me color in these gaps so the
white is what they were actually able to
perform on these tests and even these
tests are imperfect they're just
sampling the students knowledge and so
what happened to be on the test they
still didn't know some of the material
some of it I might have been careless
mistakes but some of it might have been
pretty important for example this gap
right over here might be what happens if
I raise something to the
zero power or maybe it's building on top
of a gap with negative numbers maybe
this was this gap is happening not just
because basic exponents are difficult
but because there's a gap a negative
number so the student doesn't know well
what does it mean if I take a negative
number to a positive exponent so maybe
that's a gap there but even though we've
taken the trouble of identifying those
gaps the class will then move on to the
next concept the amount of time is
what's fixed and what's variable is how
well the students understand it ABCD or
F and then the next concept let's say we
do this in another color so the next
concept here we are building on top of
everything that we've learned so far
let's say it is negative negative
exponents so I think you can see where
this is going this is this is trouble
now for the student a is lecture and
homework the student is trying the best
they can but things are just not really
gelling and so all of a sudden when you
take the quiz the student it just hits
the wall after two or three weeks and
let's say they get a 30% and so they're
only able to get 30% of the material
right that happened to be on the test
the rest they got wrong now in a
traditional system we say all right the
student just failed this exam quite
badly maybe the student needs to work
harder maybe they need to be put into a
different track maybe the subject is
just too difficult for this student but
when you look at what's going on it's
pretty clear that it had nothing to do
with the ability level of the student
and it didn't have anything to do with
the difficulty necessarily of the
subject matter but it's more that they
just kept accumulating these gaps all
along the way so at some point those
gaps become so debilitating that the
student hits the wall and starts failing
a class and if they're not able to
remediate these gaps go back well
they're never going to really be able to
understand negative exponents and then
they're never gonna be able understand
logarithms properly and more advanced
algebra and so on and so forth and we've
all seen this either for ourselves or
some of our friends and family members
they hit walls and the argument that we
believe at Khan Academy it is not
because they're not bright it's not the
the subject matters difficult it's
because we're forcing them through at a
fixed pace and to realize how absurd
this is on some level imagine if we did
other things in our life that way say
homebuilding so you tell the contractor
we have two weeks to build this
foundation do what you can and so they
build a foundation but then two weeks
later the inspector comes and says okay
the concrete's still wet right over here
this part isn't quite up to code I will
give this an 80% and you say great
that's a C let's build the first floor
and so again you try to build the first
floor maybe it rains some of the
supplies don't show up and so the
inspector comes after a couple of weeks
and says alright I'll give that a 70%
and you say great that's a D now let's
build the second floor so on and so
forth and then all of a sudden while
you're building that second floor the
whole structure comes collapsing down
and if our reaction to that is the
reaction we typically have in education
we say oh we needed more inspection or
we needed better contractors but the
problem was the process we are
artificially constraining how long you
have to do something which pretty much
ensures a variable outcome you take the
trouble of identifying those gaps but
then you build right on top of it so
this is traditional learning and one
could argue that if you're just pushing
people ahead at some pace like this gaps
will accumulate for everyone and they
will all hit a wall at some point and
we've all felt that and so a master
e-learning says look instead of making
everyone go at the same pace let us
personalize and personalization in this
context means let people go at their own
pace so traditional learning it's fixed
pace fixed pace and variable
understanding variable variable
understanding while mastery learning has
personalization so it's more of a
variable pace variable pace and then we
assume students get to a high level of
proficiency or mastery so high
expectations expectations around
proficiency or mastery
those words can mean different things in
different contexts proficiency or
mastery so in a mastery learning system
you first would maybe the student would
be ready for the negative numbers and
maybe after a few weeks they take some
type of an assessment to get as much
practice and feedback as possible and
they perform similarly to that first
example the student in the first example
maybe they get that 80% they're in a
mastery learning system we wouldn't just
tell that student all right let's move
on to basic exponents what we would do
is hey why don't you keep working on the
negative numbers here and so that you
can address those gaps and so it takes
maybe takes the student a little bit
more time but eventually they're able to
get a few they're able to fill in those
gaps they might be still a few small
gaps but the whole point is that they
can always go back and revisit and
ensure that they fill in those gaps so
that they don't become debilitating
ideally they fill in all the gaps and
now they're ready for basic exponents
and I'd argue that now that you're
tackling basic exponents one the student
actually might be able to even learn it
faster because they're gonna get less
confused by the negative exponents but
if they still having a gap when they
take some type of an assessment or while
they're doing practice they have as much
time as they need to go back and fill in
those gaps and so the whole principle
here is in mastery learning the student
is building a really really solid
foundation so that they never hit that
wall when they get to negative exponents
they understand their negative numbers
well they understand their exponents
well and so then they can just keep on
going and going and going
and it kind of got to me we believe that
if you learn this way yes certain
subjects might take you a little bit
longer but then if you invest they're
the future subjects will take less time
and you will understand more and overall
and we've seen efficacy studies to this
effect you will actually learn better
faster and you won't eventually hit some
type of a barrier like the first didn't
did with negative exponents